[Applause]
let's
have a conversation about what taylor
brought up this morning
before her crazy other question i don't
even know how she got to
which is how often do we have sex a week
that's what you ask how often do we have
sex week now i'm assuming you're asking
this
because you either want to be having sex
more or less
per week is that correct this is a
reflection of your relationship
potentially
i think you are projecting oh my god i
think you are projecting right now now
there's not
no there's nothing there's anything
wrong with it exhausting it must be for
your boyfriend to [ __ ] you with that
huge
dick that [ __ ] is a workout yo
he probably gets a sore pelvis afterward
right here these muscles
it's like exhausted it's like battle
ropes at the gym yeah do that [ __ ]
you know what i mean i'd be exhausted
too yo
that is crazy because have you ever
played mario brothers two
i don't know you know the one do y'all
know the one mario brothers two
when they're yanking like the turnips
out of the ground have you guys seen
that one
i know you're talking about the vine
that grows all the way to the sky yeah
but anyway so the point is you you want
to know what is the
average amount of sex per week how often
are you having it
and i'll tell you if it's below or above
this is personal
you see me you brought it up
well technically doesn't it depend on
how busy
each pizza yes it does so average we're
going with the average
that's why we said you're at a happy
voice to agree yes
i
honestly you deserve the full seven days
probably
[Music]
like talking to them sorry she was
thinking about that
go four to five what the [ __ ]
yeah i'm gonna play under on that one
because it depends right after about
twice a day
oh my god monday to friday a day
what now two times having sex in one day
and one 24-hour day are you talking
about you have sex at night
and then you have sex like lunchtime the
next day
are you talking about each insertion
yeah okay that's a little bit that's
within a 24-hour period
i'm not going crazy okay so when i four
to five times a week right
that is above average is it yeah how
long have you guys been in a
relationship
almost a year almost a year okay yeah i
think that's above hours how often do
you have sex a week i'm gonna be honest
when she said
how many times with a s i was like i'm
in trouble
how am i gonna fix this guys how do i
skate out of this one looking cool
once a week probably isn't that tough to
have an
average but if we're averaging less than
once a week
point seven five seven bucks
dude i'm a sex addict over here too
your boy has sex how do i get anything
else done bro
hold on once a week less than once a
week so you go sometimes yeah
realistically more than once a week but
it's tom 36 you know i mean like it's a
lot
it's a lot yeah times a week bro i need
it it's not every week so much
uh it really depends yo i hate all these
depends it depends
yeah it depends the weeks you have sex
more you have six more weeks of sex
lessons six less
you know it depends on a good week um
four to five
four to five [ __ ] that's a record
setting [ __ ]
and on a bad week it'll be just once nah
bruh yeah so this is what
your boy's out here with two but this is
that's how i do it tuesdays and
thursdays yeah
let's pull up to magnolia projects i'm
not playing games
but that's why i got monday night friday
date night tuesdays
so two times a week and that's great
i love that because i don't want sex to
ever feel like a chore
do you remember you pencil it in yeah i
know again
is that what i said
[Laughter]
this guy is [ __ ] ridiculous
hey hey is that what i said bro
tuesday's saturday is what i meant but
there's uh no no
i what i meant by like chore meaning
like ugh we gotta [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah yeah i would rather be
dying to [ __ ]
starving for a [ __ ] and then we do it
then be like ah we just gotta have sex
like get it over with
does that make sense what i'm saying
though like
when i said monday through friday as in
like maybe once
monday through friday throughout that
week and then on the weekend
it's only poppin like i told my man this
past week and i'm like we're gonna have
i haven't seen
how old is your man 33.
i'm okay with that how old are you he
works out a lot
he has stigma but he's i'm 29. well
technically 28 because i didn't count
this year but you know
wait you can't just not count okay
you can't just comment on everything she
says the whole podcast just becomes this
okay i don't even know where to begin
mark uh how long often do you have sex
well that's
okay all right we're done we got
23 brock yeah yeah he's a young buckaroo
you should be having sex
well that's the thing that's that's
different is that you like you
come twice a week you do yeah
whereas like so all sexual interactions
probably like three to four a week
okay but then also like you know oh
don't stop and stop playing with your
little [ __ ] [ __ ] get out of here
this guy's gay dude no no stop it i
don't even want to go in here now what
are you doing that when you no no no no
no
it's just so stupid well he was about to
say he's like sometimes i'll just go
down on her or nothing
no oh that's what you said excuse me
what's wrong with that but get nothing
in return
no why did you think he was going to say
that yeah well what were you going to
say
yeah oh jerk off yeah what's even
crazier that is crazy how are you three
to four times
hold on you're a maniac dude that's
crazy
out of college this is what he would do
that makes perfect sense nah he's a
nympho son
that's crazy most colleges guys are
jerking off once a day
i'm not saying it's right but that's
what they're doing no they're not dude i
was in college bro we all showered
together we jerk off every other day
together we had a dorm room we would all
shower we all be talking ourselves in
the shower
one dude would just drop out of the
conversation for no reason
it would be like ow
it's different from women yeah you grew
up in a different time dog yeah
what do you mean pre-instagram now like
now there's way more things to jerk off
to yourself colleges guys are just like
chilling they're scrolling instagram
they go oh yeah this would be fun
i am bored i do want dopamine
yeah exactly that's how it is whereas
like i feel like when you went to
college it was like oh yeah i'm gonna go
like go [ __ ]
well we had facebook dog you know what i
mean we had people and we had like real
life women that we could talk to yeah
and that wasn't weird
you could just go with you you weren't
out there getting you know finger girls
and [ __ ] in college
nah i think you said you fingered a girl
in college
you ain't finger girl in college did you
have a girl in college or some [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and you didn't
you're a hump oh you know that driver
yo she got that stroke that denim on
denim stroke
hey that bitch's left arm muscle went
numb the way she was getting stroked out
hey you might need aspen [ __ ] cause you
finna catch this
stroke you got levi stroking her bro
hold on but you're gonna leave out of
the door dude
oh bro like i was looking for a stain
where you went
[Music]
oh no check the inseam on my pants
please
that's what you're doing bro dry humps
yeah
all day uh just gonna stop me from dry
humping this [ __ ]
yeah she still probably feels it i i
feel you bro
what do we got man what's going on
bro never letting taylor start a podcast
with a question again
ever i think we opened up more no just
[Applause]
teasing